يتلحف علي وزوجته بالشمس استعدادا لبرد
الليل القارس
يتفقد خيمته بعدما فقد منزله جراء الزلزال
اكثر ما يشغل باله الان مدفاه يستخدمها
مساء
والله كل واحد له بطانيه وهذا بنتغطى
يعني في برد برد بالليل برد
برد وانا باخذ ادويتي يعني كمان باثر علي
البرد السكر بنزل لي هو لما طالع لي السكر
وانا شبكات القلب وربو وسكر وضغط عشرات
الخيام في حديقه غازي عنتاب لنازحين
سوريين واتراك فقدوا منازلهم في الطرف
الاخر من الحديقه وفي خيمه طبيه وضعت
للنازحين تتواصل المتطوعه رهف مع الاسر
التركيه باللغه التركيه من اجل فهم
معاناتهم رغم انها في زيارتها الاولى الى
تركيا ضمن فريق طبي سعودي
مساعدات صحيه زي ما انت عارف الناس الحين
عن طالعين من بيوتهم فما عندهم في ناس
كثير ما يكون عندهم ادويتهم
بارده فيكون حنا عندنا حل مبدئي لمشاكلهم
اللي موجوده الان نقدر باللي نقدر عليه
نساعدهم اللغه التركيه صعبه ولا سهله
الصراحه بالنسبه لي حساسه لانها يعني مزيد
ما بين اللغه العربيه والانجليزيه ممكن
بعض الكلمات الثانيه المختلفه اغلب هؤلاء
النازحين ينتظرون فحص منازلهم بعد وقوع
الزلزال لحين العوده اليها اخرون ماساتهم
اصبحت اكبر بعدما تهدمت بيوتهم وجاءوا الى
حديقه غازي عنتاب
يصارعون برد الشتاء عبد المحسن الحربي
العربيه
غازي عنتاب